-Welcome back!
We are talking to the one,
the only John Goodman
right here!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hopefully, you can feel
the love.
Hopefully you can feel the love
through Zoom.
You star in not only one but two
TV shows right now.
You have "The Conners"
over at ABC,
which airs Wednesdays at 9:00.
How is everything over there
at "The Conners"?
-Everything is great.
One of my daughters,
Lecy Goranson,
who plays Becky in the show
has written the script
that we're going to do
next week,
so that's going to be great.
It's pretty tight
and we have a lot of fun.
-Yeah, isn't that cool
to see the way it just --
the opportunities you get,
you know, because you --
gosh, she was a child when
she first started on the show.
-Yeah, she's still childish.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, I think you have to
be to be in this business,
right, yeah.
And then let's talk about
"The Righteous Gemstones".
This is its second season
on HBO.
Danny McBride, really funny guy.
What is happening this season?
-Uh, they're --
they're trying to merge with
another mega church.
-Yeah.
-And I have an old friend who
shows up from my days
when I was
a professional wrestler,
which I didn't know about,
but it's great to find out.
-[ Laughs ] I love that.
-I get kind of a girlfriend,
but there's all kinds of stuff
happening.
-Yeah, I know, the first episode
this season,
your character gets into
a fight in a parking lot.
But then I heard that you got
injured doing that fight.
Is that true?
-I was trying to be stunt boy.
-Yeah.
-I'm not 69 years old, I'm 23,
and I'll do this all night
if I have to.
I'll prove --
I'll prove my worth.
But, yeah, it was --
it was late in the night
and I was too tired to actually
be doing this stuff,
so I slipped in the gravel and
flew headfirst
into the back of a truck.
And you know that expression,
you get your bell rung.
That's the loudest thing I have
ever heard in my life
was the back of that truck
hitting my head.
-Wow.
-But everything turned out okay.
-Yeah. Did you have to go
to the hospital?
-Yeah, I went to the hospital.
They gave me a bunch of screens.
They couldn't tell if I've got
a concussion,
or had a concussion,
so I guess I'm okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Did they use that take?
-They couldn't tell if I had
a concussion,
so I guess I'm okay.
[ Laughter ]
-That is a professional --
a professional doing
professional comedy,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's exactly what that is.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is John Goodman in
"The Righteous Gemstones".
Take a look at this. [ Laughs ]
-What do you want?
-I just want to see
an old friend.
The older I get, the more
sentimental I'm leaning.
Nostalgic.
And I can't help but thinking
about when you and I
worked together.
-You want money.
You're going to try to blackmail
me, sell the story.
Let's not waste time here.
-Why all nervous, Eli?
Why you being all...[ Laughs ]
weird.
-You following me, that's weird.
Whatever it is you are trying to
pull here,
I don't got time for it.
-Come on, Eli.
Can't old friends reconnect?
Oh, man.
♪♪
-I-I'm busy.
Take care.
-Come on.
That's a stud right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's John Goodman, everybody!
"The Righteous Gemstones"
airs Sundays at 10:00 PM
on HBO.